national crime victims rights week
is dedicated to
crime victims to learn
about victimization
is dedicated to crime victims
to educate the community to
support us and
to let crime victims know
they have rights and that there are resources
the center offers various resources for
victims of crime the center works
with survivors of the 91 challenge
yes yes yes visit the website you can see
we have a calendar of events
we have the information if you want to
participate in the virtual support groups
and we have the information about the
financial program for
91 survivors it is important
that victims know they have rights it
is important that they have access to
services it is important that
service providers are
trained in how to work with trauma
more importantly that they know that the
community is here to support them
and survivors who
have not contacted the center and
are p  Thinking about what types of resources
we offer you can visit the management website
and there you can read my training about
the resources we offer also about
the virtual groups support groups that
we offer and also if you just want to
send an email you can
send us any  Any question the
center has wants to send our
condolences
to the survivors and families of
the shootings and violence, what is
happening makes us sad and we want
everyone to know that they are in our
hearts.